[Music]
take it home Oscar hurry
just when we thought singing with one
puppet was impressive twelve-year-old
Darcy Lin managed to outdo herself
singing with two puppets on night 1 of
the America's Got Talent finale how did
you depend I mean it was definitely my
trickiest performance and the most
challenging but I'm so glad I pulled it
off
I mean see here's Simon say I think you
are the winner of America's Got Talent
what was going on in your head I think
you're gonna win I was so nervous at the
time I don't even know but I was feeling
so happy and lucky that the judges said
that to me and it's really making me
feel really good but junior I got to say
it all started with you and you that
golden buzzer I mean you got you're
taking credit for this whole experience
right Oscar how do you feel about that I
mean you have been a big part of the
show as well you know how are you guys
going to celebrate if you'll win a
million dollars on my list but it hasn't
happened yet so you know figure that out
in the future but to know what would you
spend a million dollars on an Oscar what
does this whole experience when chewed
my America's Got Talent
a journey has been so fantastic and I
couldn't have asked for better friends
that I've made and memories and it's
just been and over the top of phenomenal
experience
[Music]
you
[Music]